okay welcome to
here and everyone who's not here I guess
I'm Paul Weiss I'm the
professor in the Department of History I
do anthropology and history and I'm here
today is a director of the Center for
the Arts Society to to introduce this
wonderful panel also to plug this event
we're having on Thursday I figured I
might as well plug it connecting with
indigenous communities through
indigenous art collections dr. James and
Brooks of the school for advanced
research so please thursday at six if
you're interested in that topic please
come back and today we're doing a panel
I think which exemplifies the top
promise and possibility of the Center
for the Arts and society here at
Carnegie Mellon the center of course is
dedicated to trying to build into spark
and and encourage work at the interface
between the Arts and Humanities between
the college of humanities and social
science and the College of Fine Arts we
don't have nearly enough sustained
dialogues between artists and scholars
in the humanities and the social
sciences and that's something that's
good to do not just because it's fine an
interesting to do so but because those
kind of conversations and collaborative
work illuminate many critical issues at
the intersection of word and image power
and practice illuminating the
possibilities of social and political
critique but also perhaps every now and
then of social and political
transformation this panel as much as and
I think perhaps more so than than any of
our other events might exemplify the
possibilities of such dialogue a title
of the panel is regime of language
change of languages in brackets how to
retool the war on terror and we're
featuring linguistic anthropologists
Adam conscious and school of our faculty
member andrew johnson now just a little
bit of background on this panel
initially we had titled it managing
perceptions we even disseminate of that
title and at some point was retitled
which i think is very much in the spirit
of this kind of reduction and
modification that's we're going to talk
about today but that initial title
managing perceptions put as well as this
current title put into a highlight how
in this war on terror narrative and its
use and
procreation reappropriation there are
many things that have been bracketed
erased redacted and rephrased although
in a sense as Anna palimpsest the
previous inscriptions remain with us in
ways that we may sometimes fail to
recognize or acknowledge foaling and I
think that I hope that this panel
encourages us to do that and it made me
think as I was preparing these notes
about Donald Rumsfeld actually who's
somebody that you know previous an
earlier US defense secretary under
george w bush and i have to admit to
missing the guy a little bit and the
reason why i missing a little bit is
because of what he would say and you
know his his statements and quotations
are legend dare and they're actually
quite revealing the one that we all know
is is a statement that was made at a
press briefing he gave in February 2002
and he was talking about you know the
criticism the administration was
receiving relating to the lack of
evidence linking the government of Iraq
with weapons of mass destruction and of
course he he what he stated was my quote
reports that say that something hasn't
happened are always interesting to me
because as we know there are known
knowns there are things we know we know
we also know there are known unknowns
that is to say we know there are some
things we do not know but there are also
unknown unknowns the ones we don't know
we don't know of which are self is a
really fantastic statement in 2004 the
cyclomatic psychoanalytic philosophers
lavage extrapolated from these
categories in an article written
response and he said well there's a
fourth element here that's been left out
by result it's the unknown known that is
that which we don't know or
intentionally refuse to acknowledge that
we do know and he writes and this will
become clearer if rumsfeld thinks that
the main dangers in the confrontation
with Iraq were the quote unknown
unknowns that is the threats from Saddam
whose nature we cannot even suspect then
the Abu Ghraib scandal shows that the
main dangers lie on the unknown knowns
that is the disavowed beliefs
suppositions and obscene practices we
pretend not to know about even though
they form the background of our public
values
and here perhaps our panelists today
will tell us not so much or not only
about the known nor the unknown nor even
that the known unknowns but also about
the unknown knowns which in a sense is a
high-faluting way to refer the way
things are made to be unknown the things
that we know that are made to to unknown
in other words to the practice of
reduction if you into reproduction in
the broadest possible sense as the
second quote I wanted to bring in from
from donald rumsfeld and april 2006 memo
this is less philosophical more
pragmatic in which she wrote a memo to
pentagon staff instructing them to quote
keep elevating the threat talk about
Somalia the Philippines etc make the
American people realize that they are
surrounded in the world by violent
extremists so in effect that kind of
politics of fear is precisely about
unknowing the things that we know are
redacting them and both quotes i think
continue to raise questions for us and
post in the post george w bush era and i
think in this panel in times of ever
escalated threats whether they're known
unknown or both i expected the panel
today will provide many new angles on
the war on terror and the perceptions
that it manages through and against some
of its many iterations reappropriation
subversions basements reductions and
Riaan scriptions and what i'm going to
do right now is just introduce each of
the panelists i'll introduce them just
before they present self up start with
Adam and then I'll introduce Andrew just
before he speaks our first speaker
Andrew Hodges is an Andrew W Mellon
postdoctoral humanities fellow he's just
began at CMU this year in the English
department were happy he's here his
doctoral work was in linguistics at the
University of Colorado with an
interdisciplinary focused grounded in
linguistic anthropology sociolinguistics
in discourse studies and his reach
research he takes a critical approach to
the study of language and communicative
practices in social and cultural life
most notably in the domains of politics
and mass media where he examines how
public discourse builds shared cultural
narratives represents issues of the
truth and constructs identities his
monograph
quotes war on terror and narrative
discourse and intertextual T and the
construction and contestation of
socio-political reality which is due out
in march two thousand eleven provides a
comprehensive look at the bush
administration's discourse about
terrorism from the events of 911 to the
beginning of the Obama administration so
we welcome Adam Hodges his talk today is
entitled discursive tactics of
resistance against the war on terror
narratives well first off let me I want
to thank Paul is in the center for the
arson Society for organizing this event
and I also want to thank the aw mellon
Foundation and the English department
for providing the fellowship funding has
allowed me to come to see in muted for a
few years so I really appreciate that
let's uh let's go back to the bush years
the Bush administration represented a
regime of government but it also
provided a regime of language for
talking about 911 and America's response
to terrorism and that regime of language
is articulated within the Bush
administration's narrative about the war
on terror so today I'm going to talk
about the discursive tactics used by
opponents of the Bush administration to
resist that narrative even as they adopt
common sound bites and talking points
that are associated with the narrative
in order enter into discussion about it
so I want to start off by taking us back
to the events of 911 in 2001 and
emphasize that those events do not
inherently contain their own meaning
rather we use language to turn those
events into a full account of that
experience so we use language to name
protagonists to ascribe motivations
provide explanations so in short we use
language to construct a narrative and
the regime of language established by
the Bush administration provided one
narrative to organize America's response
to terrorism among other potential
narratives that could have developed but
didn't so for example instead of the
plights of a nation at war
or we could have instead heard the tale
of a horrific crime in such a narrative
the events of 911 would be framed as a
criminal act rather than an act of war
were the criminals rather than the enemy
combatants would be brought to justice
to answer for their crimes but instead
Bush's narrative constructed a
metaphorical war on terror that
discursive ly laid the foundation for a
highly militarized response to terrorism
the constructionist circulation of this
widely shared cultural narrative has had
a powerful effect on shaping
socio-political reality including the
very real wars in Afghanistan and Iraq
the war on terror narrative became a way
of representing knowledge about the
post-911 world it provided a powerful
set of assumptions and explanations that
governed the way Americans discuss
terrorism as well as a host of related
foreign policy issues so the narrative
effectively framed public debate and
constrained the way the nation talked
about the issues to speak of terrorism
during the Bush administration was to
speak of a war on terror and to discuss
debate or challenge Bush administration
policy required working within the
language working with the language
associated with that narrative so even
opponents of the administration
effectively had to adopt this language
as they attempted to argue against the
policy it entailed numerous sound bites
and talking points associated with the
narrative quickly entered into social
circulation in the media as well as the
conversations that citizens had with
each other and some of these sound bites
are listed here on this slide so both
supporters and critics of the
administration both drew from this
reservoir of discourse to enter into
conversation with each other to discuss
debate and challenge the Bush
administration policy required adopting
the language of the war on terror
narrative now the examples that I'm
going to discuss today come from a
larger research project which Paul
alluded to and in that project I examine
three types of discourse in the years
after 911 first I examined a corpus of
presidential speeches that
span the last seven years of Bush's time
in the White House and using those
speeches I analyzed how the war on
terror narrative was discursive ly
established and organized I then
isolated key sound bites and talking
points associated with the narrative and
track these key phrases in a corpus of
media discourse that spanned the same
time frame as the presidential speeches
so the aim here was to examine how
language associated with the narrative
was recontextualized across different
settings and then finally the third
piece of my study involved a series of
focus group interviews that I conducted
with politically active college students
in 2007 and 2008 so the aim was to
understand how citizens such as College
Republicans College Democrats
reinterpret and reconfigure the
narrative in conversations with each
other so when sound bites and talking
points from the narrative enter into
social circulation they form the basis
of an intertextual series a text that
reoccurs across multiple overlapping
context when intertextual series enter
into subsequent contacts they index the
prior context from which they came and
they carry with them previously
established social meanings so in other
words as key phrases associated with the
narrative enter into new contexts they
effectively point2 and remind listeners
of that narrative one effect of the
recontextualization of these key phrases
in public discourse is to further
entrench the narrative in the social
imagination in this way the assumptions
and explanations contained in the
narrative become further established as
shared cultural understandings this is
particularly salient with sound bites
are recontextualized with a large degree
of faithfulness to how they were
previously used in bushes speeches but
of course meaning is never fixed
whenever discourse enters into new
context they can be reshaped in ways
that contest and challenge prior
meetings and this discursive process of
resistance is what I'm going to focus on
today I'll highlight several examples of
the way recontextualization can
challenge the dominant narrative
about the war on terror and then I'll
conclude by contextualizing those
examples within a discussion of power
and resistance so the war on terror
narrative as we've said provided a
language for talking about the topic
that both critics and supporters must
adopt in order to enter into discussion
about a wide range of policy issues so
the very label for America's struggle
against terrorism that is as a war on
terror is an obvious place to start when
looking at this language as we know
Bush's designation of the campaign
against terrorism as a war on terror
entered into common usage in American
society even though both supporters and
critics acceded to the use of this term
they have each introduced slight
modifications into how they've used it
Fox News which provides a decidedly
conservative perspective on world events
they even began capitalizing the label
with capital W and capital T on its
website in 2004 this first begins to
appear in my corpus of media discourse
in September of that year while other
major media outlets spell the term with
lowercase letters throughout the corpus
so the capitalization by Fox News
represents the war on terror as more
than a convenient metaphor and instead
as a proper noun for referring to a real
military war the turning of the war on
terror into a proper name through the
stylistics of capitalization imbues it
with historical cachet moreover and as
evidenced by much of the reporting on
Fox News the capitalized war on terror
carries with it the notion that Iraq and
Afghanistan are but fronts or theaters
of a single war which is consonant with
bushes narrative so the capitalization
emphasizes both the authenticity of the
war on terror and its nature as a
discrete and inclusive campaign now
while there is no doubt about the
legitimacy of the term within the
coverage on Fox News the term is also
legitimated in the coverage of
mainstream media outlets where the term
is still used in an
contested manner albeit with lowercase
letters now given the ubiquity of this
term in public discussion I spent a
considerable amount of time discussing
the very idea of a war on terror with
the college democrats and republicans
that i talked with and my focus groups i
wanted to gain a sense of how they
defined it and what it meant to them so
did it include the war in iraq for
example although the critics were more
likely to problematize the idea of a war
against terrorism even supporters
acknowledged the inadequacy of the
metaphor for fully describing that
struggle both Democrats and Republicans
frequently likened the war on terror to
the war on drugs they often pointed out
that the war on terror declared a war on
a problem an idea a concept or a method
rather than in their minds a nation
state which is what real wars were
supposed to do so here in my
conversation with a democrat named steve
he had told me that terror is simply a
method of conducting violence or warfare
and he not only objected to the metaphor
itself but to the entire notion of what
he says here in this clip the whole war
on terror thing so I want to play for
you how he describes this drum as you
I see that health care would be the
biggest 1i
I second that
there's the big ones in that we wore on
Jeremy
alright so even though Steve uses this
term that's in common usage he indicates
his ideological distance buy it from as
he says putting that in quote marks and
in a separate interview another Democrat
named Ted also used in his words the
little finger quotes thing to qualify
his use of the phrase so the widespread
acceptance of the war on terror label in
American society makes it difficult to
escape but social actors who oppose the
policies it entails use tactics such as
these to contest it when they do use it
a related tactic is to mark the phrase
with the adjectives so-called so that
the war on terror becomes the so-called
war on terror and this is the equivalent
of using scare quotes to indicate
ideological distance from the term now
generally speaking outside of op-ed
pieces where the writer has leeway to
indicate their ideological stance
regular news stories in the major media
avoid the so-called qualifier as already
noted mainstream media represent the
term in an uncontested manner with
lowercase letters well fox news adds
another layer of legitimacy by
capitalizing the term however I did find
a few exceptions to this general pattern
one example comes from transcripts of
Anderson Cooper's television show on CNN
and here we can see how he refers to the
war on terror as the so-called war on
terror which I've highlighted in blue so
even though his use may be limited
though to just a few instances as a
personality on CNN his use of the
so-called qualifier bucks the trend
adopted by most in the major media and
therefore does not go without notice by
those who have accepted the label and
the very idea of the war on terror such
as some of the commentators on Fox News
so this next excerpt is taken from an
editorial column by Mike Baker on
foxnews.com the response to Cooper by
the Fox News columnist in this
slide illustrates the dialogic nature of
media discourse in the bhakti nyan sense
of dialogue ism even though these two
excerpts are spoken and written in
different contexts by different people
at different media outlets they are
connected in a dialogical network where
by media events are thematically and
argumentative ly connected now
importantly the jab that Baker takes at
Cooper in this example works to police
the boundaries of mainstream discourse
through his jocular commentary and he
effectively characterizes Cooper's
reference to the so-called war on terror
as what he says a load is a load of crap
but through this jocular commentary
Baker attempts to reinforce the
acceptance of the war on terror as an
uncontested term and he mocks Cooper's
deviation from this supposedly
common-sense idea so the boundaries of
the war on terror discourse are defended
and reaffirmed now outside of the
mainstream media independent media
figures commonly incorporate the use of
the so-called qualifier into their
regular news reports an example of this
is Amy Goodman on the independent radio
program Democracy Now Goodman as many of
you may know is an outspoken critic of
the Bush administration and whenever she
uses Bush's term for the campaign
against terrorism she always refers to
it as the so-called war on terror so we
have usages of the term diverging along
and ideological spectrum on one side
foxnews authenticates the term through
the stylistics of capitalization on the
other side critics of the Bush
administration can test the term and the
very idea is that it represents through
tactics that qualify their use of this
otherwise widely accepted term now other
sound bites and talking points from the
narrative are reshaped in incremental
steps and this is demonstrated in a
statement released media outlets by then
Senator Joe Biden here this statement on
the slide appears on the Fox News
website and so you'll notice that as we
just discussed according to
stylistics Fox News capitalizes the war
on terror here but the phrase that I
want to focus on is the central front in
the war on terror Bush uses this phrase
within the narrative to talk about the
importance of Iraq in the fight against
terrorism and here Biden draws from that
sound bite but he does so in a way that
reshapes it so Biden is still working
with the war on terror discourse but
instead of Iraq as a central front he
shifts the referent in the soundbite to
Afghanistan in his statement there still
is a war on terror and there still is a
central front the only difference is the
location of that central front but by
reanimating bushes prior words he works
to shift the narrative by reconfiguring
the meaning of this sound bite now in
this slide I'm talking with Philip who's
a Democrat and he attempts to redefine
the war in iraq as a separate conflict
from the war on terror somewhat akin to
what we just saw Biden trying to do so
let's listen to Philip describe this
easy you do one wrong hands on the
warlord you live in Iraq
yes it's a civil court sunni-shia
conflict is natural there's nothing to
do with the surgeons which hackus are
just my Randy's suit yourself so as
Phillip says Iraq has nothing to do with
al-qaeda which implies that the war on
terror is solely a war against Al Qaeda
so Phillip provides a narrow reading of
the phrase coined within bushes
narrative in contrast Republicans I
spoke with provided a much broader
reading as would be expected for them
the war on terror definitely included
the war in Iraq as well as a fight
against Al Qaeda but some even broadened
the scope of the war on terror to
include all forms of what they termed
Islamic terrorism and some of them even
went beyond how Bush d limits the war
and his narrative to include terrorist
groups such as Hezbollah now both
readings are plausible as
interpretations for the meaning of a war
on terror the Republicans are more
sympathetic and read in a longer list of
neoconservative foreign policy
objectives while the Democrats are less
sympathetic and are unwilling to accept
a link between Iraq and al Qaeda but
both both the sea to the use of the war
on terror as a label as a way to label
that struggle against terrorism however
that campaign is delimited now perhaps
the most interesting aspect of
intertextual connections is the way
prior text can be reanimated through
parody parody can be an effective tool
of subversion by challenging a dominant
discourse and forwarding an alternative
perspective now one phrase that has been
parodied in various ways is weapons of
mass destruction it's been reshaped
variously into weapons of mass
distraction weapons of mass deception
and as we see featured in this slide
weapons of misdirection so this pun
weapons a misdirection was uttered by
the reverend joseph Lowery as you may
remember at the Coretta Scott King
funeral in February of 2006 with a
current and past living presidents
sitting behind him on the dais as we can
see in the photo here Lowry reshaped
the weapons of mass destruction sound
bite into an ex Corey ation of the Bush
administration now crucially lowery's
pun became a sound bite in its own right
and was replayed over and over again in
the weeks that followed in the media the
excerpt you see on this slide comes from
the transcripts of Fox News Sunday Lowry
himself was a guest on the show a week
after he made these remarks and the host
Chris Wallace introduces him by playing
the sound bite and I'll do I'll play
that for you right now we don't have any
weapons of mass destruction over there
their weapons of misdirection right now
now help ensure no hana anymore but no
more one more so this example
demonstrates how parody can be effective
at inserting alternative perspectives
into mainstream media coverage even into
the coverage of fox news which is
generally faithful to the Bush
administration's perspective here
instead of bolstering the narrative
lowry uses the phrase and his pun on the
phrase to undermine it so now that i've
shown you a few examples of these
discursive tactics i want to conclude a
bit by talking about the notions of
power and resistance power as michel
foucault advises must be analyzed as
something that circulates rather than a
monolithic or all dominant force that
flows from a single source Foucault
emphasizes the capacity of individuals
to employ power even as they undergo its
effects power is therefore productive
and not merely repressive it circulates
throughout the social body in a net-like
organization so that individuals
exercise power as they interact with one
another in fucose words individuals are
vehicles of power they are the elements
of its articulation and the articulation
of power that is the exercise of power
takes place through the discursive
articulation of the narratives that
structure our understandings of the
world in short power is exercised in
discursive interaction where it produces
forms of knowledge and constructs our
social world now in one regard this
perspective on power helps account for
the hegemonic influence of popular
discourses such as the war on terror
narrative which come to regulate the way
a topic can be talked about meaningfully
in a particular culture at a particular
moment in history within the context of
American public discourse in the years
following 911 the war on terror
narrative provided a common language for
talking about terrorism and it
constrained public discussion on these
issues the devastation brought
about by the nine eleven hijackers was
discursive ly naturalized as an act of
war that launched a war on terror with
the first front of that war taking place
in Afghanistan and the second or the
soon-to-be-called central front taking
place in Iraq now the accrual of
assumptions and explanation is about the
post 9-11 world into a shared cultural
narrative became possible through the
repetition of the narrative across
numerous presidential speeches and
through the reiteration of the narrative
sound bites and talking points in public
discourse for the war on terror
narrative to become widely accepted as a
valid incredible vision of reality
statements associated with it entered
into the public domain where they were
repeated reaffirmed and reified as julia
kristeva points out the repetition of
prior texts may be done seriously
claiming and appropriating it without
relative izing it as a result of this
process a dominant discourse like the
war on terror narrative comes to
represent a way of thinking about the
world but as Laura a her points out one
problem with the notion of a dominant
narrative is that the concept can leave
no room for tensions contradictions or
oppositional actions on the part of
individuals and collectivities yet
fucose view of power as a productive
circulating force provides for a
diffusion of power across the social
body while social actors may reiterate a
widely shared narrative in a manner that
maintains fidelity from one context to
the next and hence reproduce that
narrative strict fidelity rarely exists
in practice as Miyako in a way suggests
all discourse exists on moving
discursive ground as discourse enters
into subsequent context it is inevitably
reshaped to some degree so
recontextualization always leaves open
the possibility for the introduction of
new meanings and transformations of the
text and this is where the potential for
resistance lies so all this underscores
how an established system becomes
vulnerable to change from within that is
how change
Rises within the boundaries of that
system itself a discourse such as the
war on terror narrative constrained
social actors who draw from its
reservoir of prior words to formulate
their own articulations however this
does not preclude creativity as Judith
Butler emphasizes it is only within the
practices of repetitive signifying that
subversion can take place social actors
are not utama ton's that simply mimic
the discourse imposed upon them from a
single source of power relegated to
immutably reproduce it they introduce
subtle or sometimes not so subtle
variation into that discourse as it
moves across contexts so creativity
exists in the way social actors
assimilate adapt and rework the
discourse according to their own
interaction ille aims Americans engaged
in public discourse about 911 and
terrorism may operate within the bounds
of this war on terror narrative but what
they do with that narrative is never
fixed so thank you for listening and
look forward to your comments at the end